now Jesus peace be upon him if you
brought if he just came back today and
you start calling Jesus Jesus first he
probably wouldn't turn around because
that wasn't I mean he didn't I heard
that name yes and then if he was asked
if you asked them are you a Christian
what would he say he does not know the
word Christianity he does not know the
word Christian because Christ is
actually a latinized word the title of
the original name of Jesus which is
Messiah Yeshua Messiah or ISA Messiah
that is his real name so he would not
know what Christian isn't what
Christianity is and then if you look and
you say how did he call on God yes he
invited people to one God he
continuously reiterated this belief that
there is only one God and he used the
same name that was used but in the Bible
in the Old Testament by Moses and the
previous prophets
shema yisrael adonai elohenu adonai had
he uses the same title I don't I Jesus
uses the same word in Gospel of Mark
chapter 12 verse 29 I don't I the same
God the one the only one who has no
image no face and who is has no partners
and he uses the word on the cross nie
which is the same title in Arabic Allah
I see in this passion of the christ' if
you see this it's an Aramaic yes they
translate Allah Allah ha
yes have you get annoyed because he
pronunciation in different languages
changes for example my name is Waseem in
arabic it means handsome I don't know
whether you agree with John I'll leave
it there but I come to America they said
to me we called you Waseem you got
Indian economy was him but I remain
handsome doesn't matter how you
pronounce it so the name Allah in this
from languages they might pronounce it a
little different in in Hebrew alloy or
ello and in Aramaic ilaha but it's all
the same name God the One God that's it
it's confusing enough when he's calling
out another name for God obviously you
know he's not God but some people say he
called on God by the name Jehovah yet
now the Bible has a language concern
here every word is there's something
called jaywalking you know it adds je to
it ye saw Jesus yahuwah
Jehovah so that J has been added up it
does not exist in its original form what
my concern would be from any language
trainer the language you don't change
the pronoun the proper noun the proper
noun remains the same Eddie you call you
go to India they'll call you Eddie they
won't call you JD right
does not change it should not change the
proper noun remains the same the same
with with Jehovah the original name in
the Bible is yahuwah which resembles
very similar to the arabic name yeah hi
you yeah are you yeah hora and means the
same the everliving God we accept that
we accept that we are with it we agree
with it the only thing is we said remove
the J let the J leave
live in its own place mm-hmm and that
will solve a lot of issues okay so it's
pretty clear now some would open heart
open mind cuz he like hold on these this
is seems like Jesus if you look at it we
mentioned that he wouldn't say he was a
Creed never heard the word yes but if
you ask him did you submit to the will
of God he would say yes it's in the
Lord's Prayer not viable we'll be done
not my will but thy will though that is
actually in one word in Arabic what is
it yes exactly
I'll discord that Gospel of John chapter
5 verse 30 he says I can of my own cell
do nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just because I seek not my
will but thy will and if you translate
that in Arabic it is an a Muslim one I
am Muslim I don't do things by my will
but the will of the Creator who sent me
is exactly saying the same thing in in
his language that's what is the
translation but if someone says no a
Christian is one who submits to the will
of God no no but you can't translate it
like yeah you can a Muslim is literally
right here submits that we have God
Islam comes from the Arabic root word
Salam anson peace and Submission
submitting to the will of God and the
one who submits is more Islam that is
Muslim so the person who submits his
will to the will of God that's that's
what the title is I mean wow this is
just clear as day I mean if you just
look up to the Sun you see it but if you
turn away from the Sun you got it's
gonna see you so I can help you're not
looking for the truth you're not gonna
see it and it adds up tell us